[Music]
from the studio that owes its existence
to Michael Bay these days comes a sequel
that gave fans everything they asked for
and still kind of subs Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles out of the shadows you
wanted more turtles more characters from
the cartoon less April O'Neil and you
got it but still didn't show up to see
it anyway because when the same lazy
riders are handling the script it's not
really gonna change much inside every
human there's a dormant gene which ties
us to our animal ancestors it's as if
that purple ooze has returned them to
their rightful place in handle Kingdom
leash that's a stretch even for a Ninja
Turtles movie the heroes in a half-shell
are coming out of the shadows and they
have a bunch of crap duct-taped to them
now in a story that basically admits how
terrifying the CGI void monsters look
not monsters sorry Mikey but that's a
turtle that's a turtle that's a turtle
that's a monster what are those things
yeah watch Mikey Raph Leo and Dawn show
off their great chemistry with each
other while the humans in this movie
show up the great tips they'll sink to
for a paycheck
featuring Tyler Perry in nerd phase oh
my god yeah
multiple Oscar nominee Laura Linney
pretending to look at Turtles really and
Megan Fox reminding us why she's still
pg-13 s best porn star where did her
pants go this is a kids movie right
you remember Casey Jones awesome debut
in the comics and first film and you've
already forgotten Steve emelles version
in this one as the most badass character
in the Canon goes from a killer
vigilante to a bumbling cop that's
officer Jones I'm gonna be a detective
someday who makes rollerskates out of an
office chair and never fights alongside
the Turtles think we nailed it with this
Mugen sorry arrow you didn't but Bay &
Co aren't done yet
now all the villains sucked too as Krang
is shoehorned in to yell a bunch of
nonsense that shredder is cool with for
no reason it will open a portal through
which I could bring my war machine the
Technodrome to her I'm interested Baxter
Stockman never turns into a fly and
shredder just stands around without even
putting his costume on but hey bebop and
Rocksteady are cooler than token and
rays are so count your blessings I guess
get ready for ninja action that never
comes because there almost no martial
arts in this movie culminating in the
same blue bean sky - Ali as every other
movie this decade uh what is up with the
2010s and sky holes can we just go back
to the awkward rubber suits already it's
time to go back so get ready for a kids
movie that manages to be both dumb and
hard to follow still don't know what you
see but that won't stop Donatella from
trying to explain everything
Computers pinpointed the isotopic
signature of the purple ooze I can track
bebop and Rocksteady z' exact codons the
atmosphere around that Technodrome would
be toxic to any one of the standard
cardiovascular system
this thing's 57% complete we don't stop
it now it's gonna be ready to go in less
than four minutes
ultrasonic scanners indicate the beacons
location is somewhere near the command
module okay clearly you're just reading
from a script' there's no way you can
know that and it won't stop Michelangelo
from telling you how cool everything is
no Mikey it isn't starring Oroku Saki
you have failed this character Dwayne
the raft Johnson barf Simpson Leonardo
DiCaprio Sheldon Cooper Pizza rat oops
she's in this again don't quit your day
job beavis and butthead
diary of a mad scientist and pinkie in
the brain Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
please go back in the shadows oh but
Mikey you already did
[Music]
hey everybody thanks for watching Andy
here with some huge news for screen
junkies as you see we're growing every
day we couldn't do without you well
we're so excited to announce that we're
launching a second YouTube channel
that's right a channel dedicated to
entertainment news in the screen junkies
voice we are so happy to bring this to
you and we obviously really need some
help so when we thought how do we do
this we thought what better way than to
allow you the opportunity to join us
that's right we're opening an open
casting call or any of our screen
junkies out there in the world could
join this team and help make our team
even better so please click right here
or the link below in the description and
hopefully we'll see you here with us
it's a me a Mario old flabby man thighs
Chuck Norris doesn't dial the wrong
number you picked up the wrong phone
I demand trail by cucumber palms are
sweaty knees weak arms are heavy there's
vomit on his sweater already mom's
spaghetti